- [Voiceover] Have you ever wondered
what a chemist really does?
In this series we asked people
with chemistry backgrounds
to share their stories.
We have people from all
different fields and careers.
For example, we have
an interview of someone
who works in forensics,
which is closely related
to analytical chemistry.
We also have people from
the field of science illustration
and medicine.
Since if you've ever
thought about being pre-med,
or doing anything else
related to medicine,
you probably know by now
that you'll be taking
a fair number of chemistry classes.
We have someone who works
in industry as a researcher
developing new products.
We also have someone who
works as a programmer
at Khan Academy actually.
We have a bunch of other
interviews for careers
where it was a little
harder to find pictures,
but they're all really cool jobs.
We have fields that are covered
include patent law and science media,
which includes things
like making and producing
and hosting science TV shows.
We have an engineer who
was not a chemistry major
but had to take some chemistry classes,
and ended up using chemistry in her job.
We have an epidemiologist,
which is a really hard
word to spell, miologist.
It's also a really
interesting career, and more.
We hope to continue
adding to this collection
of interviews over time,
so please check back.
But hopefully you can tell from this list
that all of these people
who studied chemistry
are doing a lot of different things.
So there's a lot of ways
you can use chemistry
as part of your career after school.
We hope you find these interviews
interesting and helpful
in figuring out what you
might want to do as a career.